F would equal 9C divided by 5 plus 32. Nice algebra skills for figuring that one
out. We start by multiplying both sides of our equation by 9. This will create a
fraction. And keep in mind we don't multiply these 2 terms by this 9. This whole
term is distributed to both of them. So we simplify or cancel the 9s here first.
Next we distribute 5 to F and to negative 32. We add a 160 to both sides, to
isolate 5 F. And finally we divide by the coefficient of F, which is 5 on both
sides of our equation. We divide 5 into 9 C to get 9 C 5ths. And we divide 5
into a 160 to get positive 32. Here's our equation. Now there was a different
way you could've gotten to the same result by dividing both sides here by 5,
first. Then you would have just add the 32. I think that would've been a little
bit quicker.